well hi everyone my name is andrew i'm a
programmer at carbon 5.
carbon 5 is a software development
consultancy we're a friendly group of
people that love to work with you
on your software systems no matter how
big or how small
and i'm gonna bring together two
self-evident points
this is an audience that's gonna get it
maintaining large systems is really
really difficult when systems get to a
certain size
they just tend to be difficult to work
in you can't keep everything in your
head at once
additionally complex systems aren't
intentionally
messy they're not difficult to work with
because we made them that way
for the most part i mean no one's out
there like
writing code and saying oh jess wait
till wally sees this turd i leave in the
code
no for the most part we're just
accidentally adding complexity to the
system because we gotta ship things
dr dre says we got to build the business
we got to make some money
we got to secure our next round of
funding otherwise we don't have jobs
and eventually you keep doing this
enough and enough enough
your system starts to fall over when
your system grows to maybe 10 or 20
times
its intended size oops we should have
refactored maybe three years ago
the system starts to fall over and
people get really sad
and a lot of the tools we have to deal
with this
uh come from modularization
systems of abstraction well
i turned and did some looking into the
body of work that's been done into
abstraction
dave parnis in the 70s wrote this paper
while he was at carnegie mellon called
on the criteria to be used in
decomposing systems into modules
and in this text i'm just going to pull
out the core
takeaway he says that there is a list of
difficult design decisions that every
module
must then hide from the rest of the
world
design decisions that are likely to
change should be hidden
and this thought this work eventually
became what
are what we consider the modern concepts
of
high cohesion and low coupling let's go
through this
high cohesion is the idea that similar
concepts in your code belong together
they're localized to the same part of
the code base
if one changes because they're so
related the others tend to change as
well
and they also they all tend to live
together in the same part of the code
the idea of loose coupling is that your
code doesn't necessarily need to know
that much about the rest of the world
and vice versa
you don't have that many dependencies to
other systems to other apis
or to other modules
today what we're going to do is we're
going to look at phoenix context
we're going to understand this tool that
the core team has given us
to modularize and control the complexity
in our systems
then we're going to turn to kind of the
time-tested
wisdom of domain-driven design and we're
going to look at it through a
exercise called context mapping and
finally we're going to get to the code
so you ready let's get to it well in
phoenix 1.3
the core team uh released an idea of
a context um sunny over here is at the
core team
thank you very much i'm sure there's
somebody up else here that i may have
missed
and contacts are simply elixir modules
they group system functionality together
by business domains
but there's nothing magical about them
they're just modules
so let's take a look at a scaffold
when we run the scaffolding command
we'll be able to see what happens on the
other side and maybe
from there we're going to learn a little
bit about the purpose
and the goals of these contacts
so let's start i'm going to create a
user and i'm going to put it into a
context called identity
so here we go um we type it out identity
then we talk about the name of the
resource to call it users followed by
the name of the schema the table name
as well as descriptors for the columns
and when i hit enter here's what comes
out on the other side
first we get a schema that's generated
nothing here should be really surprising
to you
the only thing interesting here is that
the user is
nested in the identity module
second of all we get a module file a
context file
and this context module becomes our
public interface to the rest of the
world
now everyone else that wants to create
one of these users
is going to have a it's going to call
through one of these crud actions
in this module
third we're going to get a phoenix
controller
and the interesting thing here is that
the controller lives
in a different context it lives in the
web context
and if you look at the controller all it
does is delegate it calls through
to the context it doesn't need to know
about persistence it doesn't need to
know about ecto
it doesn't need to know about anything
under the hood that design decision
was hidden and finally we get a
migration
so what do we learn the in phoenix when
we use context
we learn that web things belong in the
web context
we learned that context encapsulate
persistence in domain logic
and finally we understand that the outer
context module
is the public interface to that module
to fro
from the rest of the system well that's
great and all but i have a few questions
number one what should i name the
context
number two how do i think about
resources that are needed in multiple
contexts
and number three how do i know if it's
too broad or too specific
what are some tools i can use to help me
understand those things
and that is a time old question
that engineers from before our time
until now have been asking ourselves how
do we design system boundaries
and so uh we turned to domain-driven
design the text
and the text was published by eric evans
in 2003
and it is both a set of high level
strategic design ideas and activities
and it's a bunch of concrete software
patterns and if you run on google and
search domain driven design or ddd
you're going to get a lot of noise
you're going to get a lot of java and
a lot of net and a lot of f sharp maybe
you're going to get a lot of like code
samples and
a lot of like jargon that's just not
going to make sense
and i don't want you to get tripped up
because there's a few core ideas that
are really golden
they're going to help you no matter what
language you turn to next
and then there's also a lot of noise so
here we go
oftentimes when we think about
abstractions we think in terms of
horizontal layers we're thinking in
terms of like we're going to need a web
tier and then we're going to need a
domain here and we need a persistence
layer
we're going to need a bunch of adapters
and that's actually a fine way to
split apart your system but what if we
had a bigger picture what if we looked
at things
a little differently and what if we
thought in terms of
vertically decomposed business use cases
now if you're working in your agile
framework of choice you're already used
to splitting things up
in vertical slices of functionality
so let's take it a little bit further
and apply it to our architecture
well i made up a company it's called
auto max
today you and i are all gonna uh get
onboarded
so here we are we're a used car
marketplace we have an online presence
we have a brick and mortar presence
sellers who want to sell their vehicles
come to our brick and mortar locations
we take their cars into our garages and
our mechanics take a look at it
we we rate their car based on the
quality and then we appraise them
for a price we buy the car if we like it
and on the other hand uh buyers come in
they see the car on the internet
they want to test drive the car and they
buy it if they like it too
well speaking of things that are design
decisions or things that constantly
change
the business is the place where i think
a lot of change happens
marketing just wanted us to change copy
on the website finance wants us to
change how tax calculations are done
operations wants us to build new
features in the vehicle inventory system
product wants us to do things in bitcoin
i don't know why
and customer support wants us to build a
better support dashboard
this is fine we got to listen to the
business
and that's not just dr dre talking
that's
dumbledore talking the right thing to do
is to business so hard it's both
my apologies for rob connery
and so i'm going to save you a lot of
money because you don't have to run out
and buy the book because i'm going to
summarize it right here on the slide and
the slide says
we design our software systems according
to
your business domains by
paying attention to the language you
speak
in the business this is important
linguistics is actually a
key thing to take away from domain
driven design
and when i say we listen to the business
i mean we literally listen to the
business
and the way we do that is through an
activity called context mapping
this is an irl get everyone in a room a
big conference room with a big blank
wall
and here we're going to discover the
concepts that live in our organization
our business and eventually our systems
so get everyone in the room
invite your product owner invite your
business stakeholders
invite your on-site customer invite
random people if you want it it's fine
get everyone in the room
and what you're going to say here is hey
um
everyone's here tech team uh
non-technical product business c-suite
whatever
everyone's gonna get a sticky and
they're gonna put up nouns and verbs up
on the wall
so from their particular point of view
in the system
what are the things that you interact
with or the system needs to do
to get your job done and it's going to
be a little chaotic and it's going to be
a little fun and
there's going to be a lot of confusion
[Music]
but this might happen
you'll see the things in orange are the
nouns and the things in blue are the
verbs
i mean uh it's never going to be this
clean but you know for the purposes of
illustration i've done it this way
most likely you're going to have
duplicates you're going to have
things that kind of belong together but
you're not really sure but
it's okay at this point we're just being
generative embrace the chaos
next what we're going to do is we're
going to group like concepts and actions
together
there's probably a natural affinity of
some grouping of these things
so over here i took the blues stickies
off the slide because it's a little
noisy and i want us to look at this
because there's actually a few things
that seem a little bit more related than
others
so we just kind of push them together
more on that in a bit
so we see that there's some natural
clusters that emerge
and i'm going to step back and introduce
the first term
from domain driven design this is the
core domain the core domain
is the primary area of focus of our
business
so in this case our company's core
domain is car sales
if we were uh if we were ikea
it would be furniture sales if we were
uber
it would be skirting federal regulations
if we were you get the point um
so you circle uh you don't have to draw
this on the wall but
i'm drawing this out here because that's
part of the context map
the context map basically implies that
all these concepts
would apply to the core domain in some
way or the other
car sales next we're going to talk about
supporting domains
supporting domains are also called sub
domains and they're areas of the
business that make
the core domain happen but they're not
the actual core domain so for example we
may have an online listings
sub-domain it's a website but it's not
necessarily
the uh the part where we sell the car we
might do financial transactions
but that's not exactly selling a car we
might optimize the funnel we might do
seo but that's not really selling the
car
and finally we might keep people happy
through customer support
but that's not selling a car
and what i want to say here here's the
point where the magic happens
is that very likely you're going to
already find some natural
groupings and those natural groupings
hint at your subdomains
and of course i'm not suggesting that
it's actually this clean
very likely some of these domains
oftentimes overlap
oftentimes they're messy you'll have
concepts that actually belong in one
and the other once again embrace the
chaos
well take a step back pat yourself on
the back because you've just discovered
your domains this context map
pointed us to our business domains in
fact they might actually point us
to real organization structures
according to conway's law and
going back to this these are the
beginnings of the
modules that we may want to build into
our application
well and if you took it even further
these may be the micro services that you
eventually wanted to
build well um here's another term
it's a ubiquitous language the
ubiquitous language
uh ubiquitous is a little misleading
but it's a it's the vocabulary that you
speak
within each domain and within each
domain
i encourage you to build a glossary what
this glossary is
it's it's super simple it's a list of
terms and definitions
for the words that you speak and here
the business
is leading always always if your product
owner
or business stakeholder uses one term
you stop them and say
do you call it an automobile or do you
call it vehicle which one do you use
oh you call it a vehicle okay i'm gonna
write that down and you turn around you
you refactor that thing to vehicle in
your code
if they say is it uh do you rate
something or do you inspect something or
you know like
get that straight be clear on those
concepts and speak about them
consistently
a nice side effect is that if you have a
glossary on boarding people is really
easy
but you never have to like have
confusions as to
what things mean when you onboard
someone so
this term of a bounded context as i was
referring to back in a few slides
these subdomains in an ideal world
should map clearly to a bounded context
so what do we mean by that a bounded
context is
has two different ways of looking at it
one is it's a running software system
so it can be a module it could be an app
it could be as a service it could be a
ruby gem
a java package blah blah blah it's
essentially code that belongs together
that eventually runs together
but there's an even more nuanced uh
definition for this
it's a delineation in our domain where
concepts are
bounded meaning i'm gonna go go back a
bit
that a concept that lives in perhaps one
of these domains
is only allowed to mean that particular
meaning
within that like that
structure within that context
and that context could be overloaded in
a different part of the system
but that's okay because we bounded it
inside of another
structure or context here's a couple
examples
a rating might mean something when we uh
when our mechanics
assign a car a rating it might mean
quality but our customer support team
might also assign a rating
and that might correspond with like a
mps score or something
those two concepts are have the same
name
but they're wildly different and because
we put them
or we nest them into different contexts
they're allowed to
fully express what they mean imagine we
didn't have any of these
any of these contacts we would have had
to awkwardly rename these two concepts
to mean something
and then you get into this weird awkward
ambiguous place where
terms don't actually mean the same thing
so the same thing happens with the user
could also be a mechanic it could be a
seller or a buyer
etc so
a bounded context means that we can use
precise language and we can model things
as
clearly and as flexibly as we need to be
a very powerful modeling tool and our
products can now stay in sync with our
business stakeholders
according to the language that they use
so to round out this entire section i
want us all to be very zealous
about the language we use about the
language we speak be very careful about
it
listen to the business we're not just
going to be our
dr dre's and we're not going to be
dumbledore's we're going to be both the
way did you know that if you put dr dre
and dumbledore together you get dddd
uncanny
okay so um it's time for some elixir
here we have a context context can
expose domain entities so here we have
the nouns that are being exposed
and they can also expose domain actions
so over here we have the verbs
that are being exposed here in our
context
a couple things about about these two
slides is that
this is using terminology that we
generated from our context map this is
terminology that our team
completely agrees on
let's assume for the sake of this next
example that we're looking at this
screen in our application a um
wally the mechanic is logged in into our
back-end admin panel
and he's uh he's giving his rating of a
certain vehicle
well here's what it looked like before
we introduced contexts
it's a little messy there's a lot of
ecto
there's this authorization policy thingy
and uh it's a little confusing so why
don't we just go refactor it
so here we're going to start out this
refactoring exercise by first
plucking the user and pushing it into
the identity context
we do the same thing for the uh for
for the action of fetching that thing
and so now
we remove the need for the controller to
understand
the the database layer or the
persistence layer
and we push that up to the context
responsibility
we'll do the same thing for the vehicle
in the rating
and we'll do the same thing for the
action in the inspection domain
so all that stuff around authorization
policies and ecto persistence
get pushed back into our context
and now we turn around and we replace
that code that we just refactored out
with calls to the context
it's way better what did we just notice
here
we just saw once again that contacts
only expose public methods to the rest
of the world
they hide internal implementations
internal implementations that are
likely to change and finally we were
very careful to use domain language
when we were naming our actions and our
concepts
here's kind of a a question i get a lot
um
is what if we need to use a concept
across
multiple content uh context
if you're like me and you've built a lot
of big apps you'll know that your
user model oftentimes becomes like a god
object
meaning that um your systems whenever
you
build any sorts of sort of system and
you have some sort of id
identity or some authorization concept
you end up
hooking a lot of things into that
concept
and eventually the dependencies to that
concept begin to spider out and cause
the system to become kind of brittle
so let's take a look at what that might
look like in our system
so in our system
the user in the identity context is
concerned
only with authentication and
authorization it might store some
facebook
tokens it might store google oauth or
saml whatever
or passwords but that's all it really
cares to know about
but however this logged in user has to
have some additional information
pushed onto it in a different context
for example like a mechanic in the
inspection domain
might have a certain like semantic
meaning about it
and it needs some additional information
additionally perhaps
we discovered in our context mapping
exercise that our marketing team
actually refers to these all as
visitors not users they call them
visitors
so here's a few options one is we could
do nothing we could just
choose to just use users everywhere
so here's what a quick refactoring might
have done for us
we uh we choose to in our inspection
domain
do a rating with a user that's a logged
in user
but really under the hood it's uh or
really to our product owner it's
actually a mechanic that's logged in
but you wouldn't know that from reading
the code obviously i wouldn't
recommend this but i understand why a
first step refactoring might lead you to
this solution
well here's a better idea is we could do
a pure uh what i call a struct
conversion but really it's just a
mapping
from an external concept into an
internal concept
and this is really useful for use cases
where you're
purely read only here's what i mean
let's assume uh in the marketing context
our visitors really uh have two
relevant attributes the handle which is
really like your email address or some
some like username or facebook username
i don't know
and then they have like an internal uuid
that we assign to them
in their cookie or something that's
really all the marketing code
cares about now
when we want to do something in the
marketing domain we need a
visitor we don't need a user so i'm
going to make this mapping function from
a user to a visitor
and over here it's um i'm sure there's a
better way to do this
but anyways what i'm doing here is i'm
basically remapping the email
field from the user struct into the
handle field
on the visitor struct and
then
when we then turn to use this in our
marketing context
we then apply the mapping function so
here you can see that we get the logged
in user but we convert them to the
visitor
and then we go ahead and use whatever we
have planned
internally in our domain over here we're
subscribing them to some email
newsletter
and over here is where the power of
elixir
really shines we're able to do pattern
matching perhaps to enforce that we get
a certain type of struct
even better we could write some type
specs to really enforce that
we're passing in the right types of
objects or the right types of
structs and finally if you really
do need to introduce a internal concept
that is persisted to the database
then you can create what i call a
collaborating schema
so if you need to write and so let's see
what that looks like for example
the inspection context might have
a a mechanic table
and we might need to persist a few other
things like a mechanic might we
might also need to know that a mechanic
is a contractor or has a certain type of
certification
and over here you can see that we just
link them to the user
and so now we're going to create
every time you enter this context you're
going to go create a mechanic from the
user or you're going to go look up the
mechanic from the user
or some combination thereof
and what we've done in these past two
examples is create what in domain driven
design we call an
anti-corruption layer what that means is
that every
context is very concerned about the
domain purity
of what's being passed around and talked
about it knows that what's coming in
from the outside world is not exactly
the perfect mapping to our internal
world
and we're going to take great pains to
actually map it
one last thing um you'll see in that
third example i
directly linked to the user
but that's actually a hidden coupling
under the hood there's a
ecto sort of relationship that may be
difficult to refactor out in the future
should this grow
so what if we sacrificed a little bit of
ease of use a little bit made a little
bit more awkward but what if we actually
enforced
some sort of like separation between our
context
and instead stored maybe uuid blobs or
we stored our user ids as strings
that way we signal to the user or to the
developer
that this is actually a hard break
one concept i want to talk about is an
aggregate aggregate is data
aggregates are data that belong together
these datas naturally fall into
tree-like structures
here's an example in our inspection
context
we have a rating for a vehicle we have a
list price on the vehicle and we have
the vehicle itself
and really naturally they really should
look more like this
now in the past maybe our context we
generated all these things
and we exposed all of the nitty gritty
gory details
out to the outside world but remember
that's
that's a that's a big surface area that
we're exposing to the outside world
and that also allows for more
possibility of bugs
and sort of like state problems
because the outside world is able to
mess with the internals of my
inspection context so what if i instead
i just returned
a nested data structure the vehicle is
what i call the aggregate root
that's like the mother object for
everything else
that just hangs off of it and then
everything else just kind of dangles off
of it and the caller
is left to parse that tree structure the
aggregate
similarly we don't allow operations to
happen on
kind of the sub resources in the
aggregate and instead we
enforce that public inter
that public methods only take aggregate
routes the only like the only way you
can change something is to tell me what
your route is
and then tell me what you want to change
on the route
so expose aggregate routes only
to the outside world and pass around
aggregates if you're exposing an api
if you're sending events on the bus
you're going to want to pass the entire
route
additionally you get the benefit of when
you pass around roots you kind of get
the context you get a
higher level view on what's actually
happening in the system
if you were just to make a change on a
line item really you want to see
what's going to actually happen in
context of the order
so um try using aggregates and finally i
want to talk about event
driven messaging and here we're getting
into some of the more
nitty gritty or some of the more
concrete software patterns in domain
driven design
but there's a simple thing we can do
here so here we have a
identity context action create user
and it has some explicit couplings
to some downstream side effects
so we're going to have to maybe create a
mechanic in the inspection domain when
someone signs up and
we might subscribe this person to an
email list and then we might then
send google analytics or mix panel a
event well this kind of couples
our contacts what if we could decouple
them somehow
and we can we can kind of invert this
sort of data flow
by instead publishing an event over a
bus
and our interested contacts downstream
can subscribe
to these domain events and in fact
when we together built our context maps
and we also developed a glossary we
actually already talked about these
these were those blue stickies that had
the verbs
that happened in our system and so
here's what i oftentimes like to do
i like to follow a three-part naming
convention for my events
the first part is the context it's the
name of the context that
that where this event originates from
the second one is the name of the
resource or the aggregate route that is
being that an action is being performed
upon or this event is being fired from
and finally it's the name of the verb
in past tense on that resource
downstream subscribers can now turn up
stream and go subscribe
to this event one of the nice side
effects of
doing this is now we get to
independently scale
downstream uh side effects should they
be particularly
slow or need a lot of time or have some
difficult
part about operationalizing them
and then there's also a downside of this
where you now introduce
the complexity of managing a bus
now i'm going to show some code i'm
going to use this library called
eventbus
it's a elixir otp implementation
of an event bus but you can replace this
with your library
with your queue or you can actually just
use straight up like
i think you can use genstage or
something for this flow
well we're going to go ahead and replace
all those calls downstream with simply
a the publishing of an event
and the details down here aren't that
important really the most important
thing is that we publish the event after
the thing happens and downstream here
you see that we send the aggregate route
out over the bus as well and now
subscribers downstream
here the marketing code is going to go
listen for that event then it's going to
perform
its own internal context side effect
on its own in fact this is another place
where we implement
an anti-corruption layer because this is
effectively
outside data coming in and this is the
same
implementation for a different context
okay every architecture talk needs a
caveat section
because your mileage may vary and i'll
tell you right now your mileage really
will
vary first of all i encourage everyone
here to start small if you're inspired
by
any of these ideas don't just go and try
to refactor everything
to use these software patterns refactor
things little by little
take one context and build it see how it
feels
was it awkward did you run into pushback
from other teams
those are all things you got to think
about uh
also you have to think about things like
did i get the concept right
refactoring and renaming things is
surprisingly really
really difficult second of all
don't get ahead of yourselves without
understanding the core concepts
of domain driven design start with the
context map
make sure you're in agreement on your
teams
that what you're doing is kosher make
sure other teams know what you're doing
make sure that you're always updating
your glossary with the latest
terminologies
and you're doing your best to keep
things consistent from your business
stakeholder all the way down to your
code and finally if your system if
you're not feeling the pain
don't do this i just told you to do this
and then at the end i told you not to do
it
this is only for systems of certain
scale and for teams that feel certain
pains
if you have a small scale system if you
have a crud based app
that's honestly not doing that much you
don't need this
so don't do it in conclusion
what i've hope i've showed you is that
it's important to listen to the business
you got to build a context map which
will help you and it'll guide you toward
using the right
the right boundaries in your code you're
going to create a glossary you're going
to use the right words
we're going to be very zealous about
using context
to hide implementation details
we're going to be we're going to embrace
the nuances of language
we're going to use our phoenix context
or just our modules
to to specifically allow languages to
to allow concepts and terms to run free
we developed a few architecture tools
and we are probably on the best
most robust system to build all these
contexts
if you ask me that's what make really
beautiful systems
all right go on everyone i've given you
the power use your powers for good
not evil thank you very much